dos veces por semana olena visita el
cementerio de lucha
Aquí está enterrado su marido olexey fue
de los primeros en enlistarse cuando
Rusia lanzó su invasión tenía 46 años y
muy poca experiencia militar murió dos
meses Después de llegar al frente
alcanzado por un mortero a olena le
avisaron por teléfono
y
sencillamente me llamaron y me dijeron
que habían encontrado su cuerpo por lo
que necesitaban fotografías de él para
identificarlo eso fue todo
es presidenta de una de las asociaciones
que dan apoyo a viudas y familiares de
soldados muertos en la guerra le
preocupa la gran cantidad de
combatientes desaparecidos
Tenemos un gran problema con los
intercambios de cuerpos desde el 24 de
febrero de 2022 no hemos podido
recuperar casi Ninguno de los
territorios ocupados por Rusia
Esta es la casa que tetiana estaba
construyendo con su marido
Brasil murió gersón y dejó huérfana a
Verónica de 5 años
su esposa cuenta que aún no ha acabado
el proceso para formalizar el deceso
hemos terminado todo el papeleo y
rellenado todos los documentos y estamos
esperando aún no tenemos noticias
la demografía de Ucrania está cambiando
drásticamente con la guerra
cada jornada de combates decenas de
hombres se van para no volver y la vida
de sus familias cambia para siempre